MIKE WOLFSON: Thank
you for coming, guys.
My name's Mike
Wolfson I am going
to talk about Android
developer tools.
I recently-- we'll
get into it-- just
wanted to give you a quick
concept of what the agenda is
so you guys have an idea of what
we're going to be doing today
I'm going to start off
with an introduction
both about myself
and about the tools.
We're going to talk about
ADT and Command line tools,
Emulator, talk about
some shortcuts for coding
and then we'll talk about
performance monitoring
and things like that.
I just want to give you an idea.
I've given this talk previously,
I've given it a few times,
but this particular slide
deck came from OSCON.
Their presentations are
targeting 40 minutes which
is not a lot of time
so I've expanded it
quite a bit for
this presentation
but I think it'll go about, I'm
targeting just about a little
over an hour, hour
and 15 minutes.
If you want to ask
questions, go ahead
and raise your
hand and interrupt.
Obviously if I can't
answer it or if it's
too much of a digression
we'll just move on
and I'll answer afterwards.
I mentioned I've given this
talk a few times at OSCON
and DevCon, and a
few other places.
Generally, I have had live
demos in the presentation.
When I did this talk for
OSCON I put all the demos,
kind of as slides,
and everything
went so much smoother.
So there won't be
a lot of demos,
but if there's something that,
in particular you want to see
we can do that afterwards.
I'd be happy to show you
how to run any of the tools,
specifically, how to
run any of the demos,
or any sort of questions.
So we will tackle
that afterwards.
OK, so just a
little bit about me.
I guess the most
important thing about me,
is I run the Phoenix chapter
of the Google Developer group.
I founded it, I've
run it for I don't
know how many years, but
anyway I run a Google Developer
group in Phoenix.
I love the community and I love
just getting people together
to talk about tools and stuff.
I'm also a full time
Android developer.
I currently work, I live in
Phoenix, I work for a company
here in Silicon Valley, in
San Mateo, named Epocrates,
they're a healthcare
point of service app.
Some people, maybe,
have heard of them.
And I am a full time
Android developer.
That's what I do in
my day job, and that's
also what I do for fun.
So I've been lucky
enough to find
a job that allows me
to do my hobby for fun.
Previous to that, I have about
15 years of experience, mostly,
in Enterprise Java Development.
So for the first
book, can anybody
tell me what's unusual
about this picture?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Why is there,
there's like some piece
of paper [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: You have
a cheat sheet?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I see a KitKat.
MIKE WOLFSON: No, that's
an ice cream sandwich.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: OK, well
actually the statute
is not correct anymore.
The Jelly Bean
statue was changed.
This picture was taken the
day that the Jelly Bean
statue was unveiled.
And they changed
the top of that.
It doesn't have a
clear dome anymore.
Now it's got a bit
of green thing on it.
So, there'll be other
chances to get books.
I also want to mention, if
you guys don't particularly
want a hard copy
of the book, I'm
more than happy to make the
soft copy available for download
for free.
So just keep that--
[APPLAUSE]
That's great.
So obviously that's
between you, and me,
and not O'Reilly, but anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
But I do want you guys to
know that if you really
are interested in the book, come
up and talk to me afterwards.
I'll give the URL, where
you can go download.
I have all four different
types of DRM-free books
in my Dropbox.
So I'll share that link.
So I just want you
guys filled out.
OK, we talked enough about this.
I just published this
book for O'Reilly.
It's been out about
four or five months.
So I've always been passionate
about the Android Developer
Tools.
They sometimes have
some challenges
in understanding how to use
them, and how to run them.
So I figured it
would be a good topic
to share because I think
it's really important.
I think the tools
are really fantastic
and that the project, and
the team are really great.
I think the discovery and
usability of the tools, not
usability, but the discoveries
can be challenging.
So that's why I wrote the book.
The other thing is I
am an active developer,
and for fun I have a app in the
market called Droid of the Day.
It is a App of the Day app.
Basically, everyday you'll get
a notification of a new app.
It's been in the market
for quite a while.
It's got a decent number
of downloads and it's free.
So if you're interested
in apps, check it out.
The other thing I'll mention
is if you're an app developer
and you'd like to see
your app featured,
this is a good way
to get visibility.
And part of the
reason that I run
this app is because I like to
help independent developers
find an audience, which can be
challenging in the Play Store.
If you're a developer,
let me know,
and I'll see about
featuring your app.
OK, real quick, I just
wanted to tell you
a little bit about some
presentation resources.
These slides are all
available up on SlideShare.
So they're available.
There's an old copy there now.
After this
presentation I'll make
sure I upload the newest copy.
But that's what the
URL will be there.
The other thing I
wanted to mention
is, when writing the book
and for this presentation
I did generate a project,
an Android project that
is designed to help run the
demos and generate examples.
So it's a pure GitHub.
So if you want to
download that, that
should help you
run all the demos
and you'll see throughout
the presentation
there are certain times
where I might reference that.
So in regards to that any time
that you see a gray box down
at the bottom in that style
that's going to infer it's
a tool, it's something
for you to try
at home, or a
Command to type in.
So when you see
that box that should
key you in to know
that you have homework.
OK, so that's enough about me.
Let's talk a little
bit about the tools
and then we'll get into the
nitty gritty of actually using
the tools.
So the first thing I want
to mention about the Android
Developer Tools is that they
are free and Open Source.
So I don't want to make
a political statement
about Android, but the Android
AOSP is realistically not
Open Source.
They don't take
submissions and it's not
developed in the Open Source.
They give it to the
Open Source community
after it's been developed.
The difference is the
Android Developer Tools
are developed
completely in the open.
There is a open branch
that you can go check out
the latest revisions
of the code,
and they do take submissions
if you have a fix or something.
They do accept submissions.
So it's a much different
sort of project than Android.
And the other thing that's
important to mention
is it's run
independent of Android.
They are not necessarily
the same team,
they're run differently, they
have different schedules,
and they have different
kind of ways of operations.
So they're very, very different.
Tools on Android.com
is the location
where you can get all
the information you
need about the tools.
I will also say this about
the Tools Development Team,
is they're very open,
and very available.
You'll see that they're
answering questions
in the group chat, they're
not very secretive,
and they're very open.
So it's a really a
great team, and they
seem to be run
really well, and I
think they've done a great job.
OK, so let's talk about
the tools a little bit.
I think you guys
are probably all
familiar with the
Eclipse-based ADT.
That's basically the tools that
we've been using for many years
now, very, very stable,
very rock solid.
At Google I/O this year they
introduced the Android Studio.
Android Studio is a new
flavor of Android IDE
and it lives along side of the
ADT, Android Developer Tools.
Now I do want to say
something very important,
and I have verified
this, this doesn't
mean that the Eclipse
based tools are going away.
It just means that there's
a new flavor involved.
We can talk about why they're
doing this, if you'd like,
after the presentation.
When this first came
out, a lot of people
thought, "Oh man, now I
got to learn a new tool,
Eclipse is going away."
AUDIENCE: So is
[? Tulle Norve ?] a member
of this tools group? [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: Yes,
absolutely, [? Tulle Norve ?],
[? Javier ?] [? De Roshe ?]
those are the two big names
that I think are the
most representative.
So it's important to know that
just because they introduced
Android Studio, doesn't
mean that Android Developer
Tools are going away.
The Eclipse based tools
are extremely stable,
they're very feature rich, and
they have a huge user base.
There would be no reason
for them to abandon that,
and just to drive
this point home,
they're not abandoning Eclipse.
So let's give it a little
analogy of the difference here
between the two tools.
So I kind of consider Eclipse
like a gold Camry station
wagon, really
reliable, rock solid,
is going to get you
where you need to go,
but you may not look
that great getting there,
and it may not be that
much fun to drive.
Whereas, the Android Studio is
much like this Ferrari F430,
that is rockin' fast,
and handles great,
but if you don't know
what you're doing,
you're going to wrap
yourself around a tree.
AUDIENCE: It's mightier
than the Eclipse then.
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah.
Android Studio is definitely
the sexy hotness, quick,
but if you don't know
what you're doing,
or you don't necessarily
have a reason
to be using Android
Studio, I would strongly
suggest that you stick with the
Eclipse-based tools for now.
They're stable, there's a
huge community of support
around them, and all the
questions are answered,
things like that.
And we'll talk just
a little bit more
about what Android Studio is.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So how
much of the code
is the Android's
common [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE WOLFSON: I don't
know about a percentage.
I do think some of
the tools are common,
but I don't think they
share a lot together.
But I would have no way
to know the percentage.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat questions?
MIKE WOLFSON: Oh sure.
Sorry about that.
The question was,
how much code is
shared between Android
Studio and ADT?
And the answer is I don't know.
OK, so let's talk a little
bit about Android Studio, what
it is, so that you
kind of know some
of the key differences
between that
and the Eclipse-based tools.
So Android Studio is
based on the intelliJ
IDE, so a completely
different IDE,
has different key commands, a
different way of doing things.
It also implements
under the covers,
the new Gradle-based
build system.
Now I just want to mention about
the Gradle-based build system
you don't have to use
Android Studio for Gradle.
You could also run
your builds, your clips
builds, using the Gradle build.
And if you look in the
export, file export,
you can actually
export out of Eclipse,
you can export your
Gradle build files.
So if you want to play
with Gradle, which
is a whole other discussion that
we're not going to get into,
what Gradle is.
I would strongly
suggest that you
start thinking about Gradle.
I mentioned that Android
Studio is not replacing ADT.
Gradle is replacing ANT.
So they have said that Gradle
is their future build system,
and is deprecated.
So you want to
start using Gradle.
And Gradle is really well
designed for Android.
It allows you to generate all
sorts of different builds,
just right from the build
tool, things like that.
So, again, I'm not sure I'd
suggest using Android Studio.
I would suggest checking
out Gradle and trying
to come up to speed on that.
I think that will benefit you.
One really great thing
about Android Studio
is they have a really
rich visual editor.
So they have a real
time visual editor
that will allow you to
make changes in your code
and look at the
changes as they'd
be represented in
your UI directly.
So they also have a really
rich drag and drop UI builder.
It's clear that,
that's like something
that you get, really good,
out of Android Studio.
The other thing, is they
have really good integration
with Google Cloud services.
I haven't done this myself,
but what they demoed at I/O
was you could look at your
data model, right mouse
click on the data model,
and generate a code that
would allow you to create a sync
to the Google Cloud services.
So pretty cool stuff.
And no doubt Android
Studio is going
to really keep innovating.
And we're going to see a lot of
movement with Android studio,
and not as much as
ADT, but for now.
And this is the last bullet.
It's still an early
access preview,
which means it's alpha,
for the most part,
not even beta, is buggy,
it is certainly influx,
and it is not for
the weak of heart.
So, I think statement made.
AUDIENCE: How stable
is Gradle Build System?
[INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: I would suggest
using Gradle now, yes.
It is stable, yes.
It's still, also
pretty dynamic, but I
would suggest using
Gradle now and I
do think it is stable enough
to be production quality.
There's probably going
to be some features that
aren't implemented yet.
But maybe if you're
an early adopter
you can help drive
some of those things
by communicating those
needs and things.
I should have done
this earlier, can I
just see a show of hands of how
many people are active Android
developers now.
Great, and how
many of you people
are really comfortable
with the tools
and think you really
know how they work?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, well I do cover
a lot of the basics
and I added some more advanced
stuff to this presentation.
So hopefully I will have some
stuff of interest to everybody.
AUDIENCE: So the nice
thing about Eclipse
is that it clones
Java and sync so it's
easy to create [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: Well, yes IntelliJ
is an IDE just like Eclipse.
So you can do different projects
of all different flavors,
web projects, C++ projects.
AUDIENCE: Just [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah
OK, so historically,
if you wanted to install
the Android Developer Tool,
you had to download a bunch
of different components,
the plug-in, the IDE,
the Java, et cetera,
and then wire them all together.
Fortunately, this
is all gone away.
And now, for both Android
Studio and Eclipse,
there is a downloadable bundle.
And this allows you
to just download
one platform specific
zip file, install it
on your system, and
everything works.
So the reason I included
this in the slides
is because it's
really important.
If you're working with an
old Android installation
and you're scared to touch it
and every time you upgrade it,
it's fickle, and
you have issues,
wipe it away, delete
that completely,
and start with a bundle,
because it is so easy.
In fact, frequently, if
I do have those problems
that I can't get an upgrade
to work, or whatever,
I wipe away my Android
installation completely,
download a brand
new bundle, which
is going to have all the current
latest code already in there
and working.
So don't be afraid of
the bundle and if you
are having any
challenges don't be
afraid to just wipe your
system and start fresh.
The only challenge
with the bundle
is it's about 400
megabytes a download.
So the biggest problem is
getting that big download
the first time, after that
it's as easy as could be.
OK, so I'm going to move on
to the Android Debug Bridge.
Android Debug Bridge is
kind of what the name says,
it is a bridge that allows
you to debug your Android
device from your computer.
So this is basically a
command line tool and also
a communication
tool that allows us
to interact with
our Android devices.
The important thing to note
here is an Android test
device can be an emulator or it
can be actual physical device,
and for the most
part, there's not
a whole lot of difference
between those two things.
So this is one of those cases
where you see a gray box that
allows you to, these
are some commands
I would encourage you to
try on your own later.
Obviously, ADB Help
is super simple,
but you can see
the kind of things
that you can do with ADB.
You can push files
from your device,
you could pull files, you can
install an APK, and run an APK.
There's a lot of more
advanced stuff you could do.
You can actually install an
APK, and run a single activity,
and that activity doesn't
have to be the main activity
in your manifest,
the one that is
marked as your main activity,
a ton of flexibility.
Now the cool thing is because
these are Command Line
tools that flexibility
is available to you
to script, or without
any sort of rich UI.
I assume most of you
guys had used ADB.
The other really
common use for ADB
is if you're ROMing
and rooting your phone.
Obviously, ADB is
the main tool you
use to do that, to unlock
your bootloader, to push files
onto the phone,
things like that.
There are a ton of
stuff you can do.
I'm sorry, the one last
thing I wanted to point out
was this one at the bottom
which actually allows you to,
well there's two things.
There's two last bullets.
The first bullet
ADB shell allows
you to open a shell command
on your Android device
and operate any of
the commands that
are involved in a shell, LS,
NV, et cetera, et cetera.
Now the shell that
comes with Android
isn't a complete Linux shell,
it doesn't have all the commands
that a regular Linux shell has,
but you could do a whole lot,
and ADB shell allows
you to actually remote
into your device and do any
sort of things that you want,
look at the system, inspect
files, et cetera, et cetera.
But the really cool thing
it also allows you to do
is, you can open
a SQLlite command
and intraspect your databases.
So if you are doing
database command
and you want to figure
out what's in your tables,
your table structures,
et cetera, et cetera.
There's a SQLlite's
command that allows you
just as if you were using
SQLlite on any other system.
The other really important thing
that we do with ADB is Logcat.
I'm sure you guys are
all familiar with Logcat,
but I would guess
that you're not
familiar with all the
things that it can do.
So I just want to run through
a really quick example
of some simple stuff in
Logcat, explain how it works,
and explain some advanced stuff.
So the first thing you
could do with Logcat.
Logcat has two sort of concepts.
The first concept is
a verbosity level.
Just like you guys, I assume,
you guys have used Log4j,
where you can set
the debug level
to verbose, debug, et
cetera, [? bug warn. ?]
That same concept
exists in Android,
so when you create
a log statement,
so like this one
in my Java class,
you can set a verbosity level.
In this case, I have
D set, so debug.
But the cool thing
about Logcat is
you can also associate a
tag with your log message.
So in this case I have this
myTAG tag and then the log
message.
What this allows
you to do is, you
can filter based on the tags
that you create in your code.
So generally what you do is,
when you're writing your code,
you create tags that are
specific to functional areas
that you want to test.
Then you can filter
based on those tags
and see how your code
progresses through
that particular functional area.
So a quick example,
this is a Logcat,
where I have not performed any
sort of filtering based on it.
Again, I'm sure you guys have
looked at Logcat messages.
There's a ton of stuff that goes
through, especially if you're
using a real physical
device, there's
all sorts of system
events happening.
If you want to see what
you're looking at you've
got to look real closely, and
you got to look real careful.
So you can see, I
have those tags,
but if I didn't have
them highlighted here
they'd be pretty hard to
figure out where they were.
So all you'll do is if you
do want to see Logcat related
to your particular tags you just
issue a command, Add Logcat,
MyTAG:0, then the important
second part of that command is
the not colon so
tag, colon, star.
Before the colon, is the
tag, the part after the tag,
is what verbosity
level you want seen.
So in this case I say I want
all verbosity levels for tag
and the second
important thing is,
I want to silence
everything else.
So that's what the
star, colon, S means.
And when I do that, you can see
that now I can very clearly see
exactly what I'm looking for
and all the fluff is gone.
Now that's pretty cool.
You can filter based
on a single tag,
but the important
thing is you can
filter based on multiple tags.
So in this case,
this example shows
I'm filtering based
on my own unique tag.
I want to see my tag.
But I'm also
interested in seeing
how my tag relates
to PackageManager.
So, basically you create
that command, myTAG, colon,
asterisk, PackageManager, colon,
asterisk, and then don't forget
the asterisk, colon, S
to silence everything
else, and you'll see now I
have just the information
about the two tags
that I'm interested in,
and you can create as
many different filter sets
as you want.
You can string multiple sets,
and of course you could also
filter based on a tag, and
a verbosity level combined.
So there's a ton of flexibility
and if you design your log
messages with
these tags in mind,
it is a indispensable tool
when you're trying to debug.
It allows you to
really drill down
to see just the
stuff you care about
and remove all the other fluff.
So that's just basic Logcat.
Did somebody have a question?
So that's just basic
Logcat, but you
can do a whole bunch of
other stuff with Logcat
and I leave this
slide for you guys
to try when you're at home.
You could also, if
you're interested in only
a particular buffer, like the
radio buffer, or the events
buffer, or the
main buffer, which
is the default in this case, you
can specify a particular buffer
that you want to see.
So you can filter, so you're
only seeing the radio buffer.
That's the only
messages you care about.
Obviously, that depends on the
type of code you're writing.
There's also a variety of
pre-defined output formats.
So brief, is the
default and that
specifies different parameters
that will be output,
but time is a really
useful one that
appends the time, which isn't
in the basic log functionality,
and again you can add these
command lines, these command
line arguments, in
addition to the tags.
So you can see there's a
really rich, rich set of Logcat
functionality.
The last thing, I'm
not going to demo,
but is really worth exploring,
is the Logcat tab in Eclipse.
This allows you to save a bunch
of filter sets, and tag sets,
so you don't have to
type them every time.
You can actually, save a
tag set, and click on it,
and it will filter
based on that.
And the other really cool
thing that the Logcat viewer
and Eclipse has
is a regex editor.
So you can actually
search your logs
using regular expressions,
which again is really rich.
So as developers I'm
sure you guys all
realize that logs are
really important, especially
when you're in the midst of
trying to figure something out
and Logcat really
allows you to get
at exactly what you want to see.
Good.
OK, so that's Logcat.
Let's now talk a little
bit about emulators.
I want to address,
first of all, some
of the capabilities
of emulators,
and then we'll talk about
some of the limitations.
First thing you can
do with an emulator,
is you can simulate telephony.
So you can simulate
latency, or connectivity,
or simulate events, as
in SMS, or a phone call.
You can't actually
make a phone call,
but you can simulate
a phone call.
You could simulate location,
including KML, or a path.
You can specify
a single location
that your emulator is
supposed to emulate.
You can emulate a variety
of different hardware.
Now that's the important
thing and the reason why
we want to use an emulator,
is there's a lot of Android
devices in this world.
I think, the last time I looked
at my Droid of the Day console,
that my app currently supports
like 3,000 different devices.
Even if I was
really, really rich
I wouldn't be able to purchase
all 3,000 of those devices
to test with so using
emulator allows me to simulate
a variety of different
hardware configurations
so that I can at least get
close and know for the most part
now there are some limitations
I guess which we'll get you
in a second on emulators.
AUDIENCE: Does it emulate
all the different resolutions
of the different devices?
Can you do that?
How accurate is it?
MIKE WOLFSON: So
the question was
if you want to emulate different
resolutions of devices,
can you do that and
how accurate is it?
That you absolutely
can do you can
actually I'll show in a
second when I show you
how you set up an ABD you could
specify a preset resolutions
or you could actually
create your own.
So for resolution,
you absolutely
can emulate it, exactly right.
What you can't do, we'll
get to in a second.
What you can't do
is emulate the skins
that the manufacturers
put on their devices.
So Touchwiz is
MotoBlur, I guess,
I don't know if that exists
anymore but TouchWiz or LG
skin, those you cannot
emulate in a emulator.
AUDIENCE: Is it better than
like [INAUDIBLE] Nexus10
MIKE WOLFSON: Well
actually that's
now a little different things.
So the question was
there's a process
that you can use
with the Nexus 10.
Using adb, you can
actually have the Nexus 10
emulate different
resolution sizes
using [? netsome ?] commands.
So the question was, is
that a better approach,
or is using an emulator
a better approach?
And the answer is, it depends.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
locations, what
are the different options?
[INAUDIBLE] GPS, [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: It is LatLng.
It takes LatLng, [? KML, ?] and
one other type of format of-- I
can't think of the third.
GPX?
Is that a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: What is it?
OK, well there's three types.
I'm not sure of the third.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] arm
emulation emulate [? all ?]
counters that are available
in some [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: The question
is, does the arm emulation,
basically does it perform
the same as a real arm phone?
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Some new arms come with
performance counters
so you can figure
out [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: So the question
is, does the emulator
perform the same as a device?
The answer is no,
definitely not.
If you're doing really
performance testing,
you probably want to
use a real device.
There's so many variables in
an emulator, both the device,
the physical device
it's on, your computer,
how many other things
it's working on,
et cetera, et cetera,
the performance
is not going to be
accurate to what
you would see on a real device.
AUDIENCE: So intelligent
testing on the Android market
[INAUDIBLE] I think it
would be a good idea
to use a x86
emulator just to test
[INAUDIBLE] x86 [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: So the comment
is, in addition to AMD,
you also may want to test
using the Intel chipset,
because there are
Intel phones around.
And I'm actually going to
discuss that in a second,
because there's other
advantages in addition
to just emulating Intel chipset.
So I am actually going to
touch that in a second.
Last thing you can
do with the emulator
is you can do media actions,
but only audio, not video.
You cannot do video
on a emulator.
Some of the limitations
of things you cannot do
on a emulator include
Google services like Gmail,
or the PlayStore,
things like that.
Now there are ways to hack
that on to your emulator,
so there are ways to
work around this issue.
But out of the box, it is not
designed to run Play services.
And I think there's
obstacles, and there
will continue to be obstacles.
They don't want that
on the emulator.
You can't make real phone calls.
I think we already
kind of discussed that.
Certain graphic
support, again, this
is getting back to kind of
what we were discussing before.
The performance is not
the same, so if you're
doing a game or
something that requires
very precise
graphics performance,
the emulator is probably
not the right place
for you to be testing
your functionality.
The other thing that's limited
on a emulator is touch events.
You have a mouse to
interact with your device,
so multi-touch or certain
other operations are limited.
You just can't do that.
AUDIENCE: So for multi-touch
[? on a laptop ?],
[? a ?] touch screen
laptop, [? do you think ?]
they're going to support
that in the future?
[INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah,
so the question
is, using either a touch screen
monitor or a computer that
has a multi-touch
keypad, will they
support multi-touch
in the future?
I don't know the
answer to what they're
going to support in the future.
There is a ADB
bridge that allows
you to use your device as a
touch sensor for your emulator.
So again, as I'm sure
everybody in the room
knows, and anybody that's
done professional Android
knows, when the question
is, does Android do it?
The answer's always yes.
Because it's such
an open platform,
there's always some way
to get what you want done.
If you have enough time,
money, and resources,
you can do pretty much anything
you want with these things.
But out of the box,
it's not supported.
There is limited
accessory integration.
You can use USB and headphones.
And the other big
limitation of emulators
is they're really slow.
Slow to start, they can
be slow to deploy to,
and they can be slow to run.
So I am going to show you some
tips on how you speed it up,
but again, I'm sure
everybody in here
knows when you start
your emulator, it's
time to go grab a cup of
coffee, or go check out Facebook
or whatever, because
you're going to be waiting.
It can take three minutes
for an emulator to start up.
OK.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: So the
question is, is it
possible to emulate Bluetooth?
I don't know the answer to that.
I would suspect not,
because that-- I don't know.
I was going to say because
the computer hardware would
require Bluetooth.
Of course, most computers
now have Bluetooth.
So I don't know if you
can emulate Bluetooth.
That's a good question.
In fact, you get the first book.
All right, so as I
mentioned, there's
lots and lots of Android
devices in this world.
Every device on this screen
runs Android, or at least
interfaces with Android.
So it's really important
that you understand emulators
and understand how
you can use them
so that you can be able
to test on the biggest
variety of devices possible.
I think in a
professional world, this
doesn't excuse you not having
a variety of actual devices
to test on.
But emulators will get you
a good distance of the way.
So let's talk for real quick,
we'll take a quick diversion.
Let's say that you don't
want to use an emulator.
You can use almost any Android
device as a test device.
There may be very
few exceptions,
but for the most part,
any Android device
works as a test device.
The only thing you need to
do is enable this check box
in your device settings app.
So basically, you just
need to allow your device
to run applications from
outside of the Play Store,
and you can run any app you
want on your Android device.
I'm sure there
are some, maybe, I
assume probably the
Kindle Fire doesn't
allow you to do that,
some other things.
But for the most part, any
device that's available now.
The challenge is, after OS
4.1, they hid-- I'm sorry,
so that particular
function, actually, I'm
not sure if that function
is hidden in developer tools
or not.
But that's the step one.
Step two that you're probably
also going to want to do--
AUDIENCE: It's not.
MIKE WOLFSON: Good.
AUDIENCE: It's in the main area.
MIKE WOLFSON: OK great.
So allowing apps
from non Play Store
is not hidden in
the developer tools.
But, you're going to want to
access the developer tools,
enable the developer
tools on your device,
so that you can debug directly
into the device, hook up a USB,
things like that, in addition
to some other things.
Now the challenge is, in
OS 4.1, they hid that.
So this used to be
an item that was
available in your settings app.
You just had to go
find it and enable it.
Now, it's hidden.
So the way to get there now
is you click on the About
Phone button seven times, and
at the end of the seventh time,
you get a nice
message that says,
congratulations,
you're now a developer.
And that shows up in your list.
AUDIENCE: Really, it will
even count down for you.
You will start hitting and
it will go like, 4, 3, 2, 1.
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah.
So the comment is, once
you start hitting it,
you'll see click seven
times, six times, five times,
four times.
I'm not sure, but I think
that might move, actually,
what you have to click.
I thought I might have had to
click the build for KitKat.
AUDIENCE: It was
About Phone when
I rooted my Seven, so,
that was for KitKat, so.
MIKE WOLFSON: OK.
OK, good.
So anyway, that's what
you want to do now.
The cool thing is,
basically what I just
told you is how you can use
your phone as a test device.
But the developer options that
I just showed you how to enable
have a ton of really great
functionality in them.
And it's all based on testing
on your device, itself.
Obviously, USB
debugging allows you
to hook a USB device
into your phone.
That's pretty normal.
But the other things
you can do in there,
and I really encourage you guys
to go look in the developer
options and just start
playing with these things,
are allowing mock
location, so that
allows you to specify
some of the locations
we were just talking about.
Strict Mode allows you
to flash your phone,
it flashes your phone red
when you're doing operations
on the main UI thread.
Which, as good
Android developers,
you never want to do
long running operations
on the UI thread.
So there's just
a check box there
that allows you to quickly
see, and it's really obvious.
In fact, I run
this all the time.
I have strict mode enabled
on my device all the time,
and it's interesting to see
how many apps are being bad.
But as a developer, it's
really great for you
to be able to see when
your app is being bad.
And it's really in your face.
You could show touches, so if
you're doing a presentation
or something, it will
highlight the touch points
you're pressing on your device.
You can change the animation
and transition scales
so that you can get a closer
look at the animations
that you're using, and
if your debugging those.
You could also select-- and
this is just a small list.
There's a lot of stuff in there.
You could also, one,
don't keep activity.
So this will kill
the activity as soon
as it closes, which allows
you to mess with state
if you're doing
particular operations.
So the developer options
that are on the phone
are really, really
rich, and something
that most people don't use,
but something that you should.
And they're really
low risk to play with.
Just go enable your
phone, go start playing
with those things.
I mean, you're not going
to mess anything up.
Basically, these are just
visual cues and things.
But I think you'll learn
a lot running your app
and enabling some of these
different developer options.
OK, so remember
all these devices,
and remember that
we can't possibly
afford to buy them all.
Let's say that we just
want to concentrate
on that top little area,
the phones and tablets.
That's where you
really want to start
talking about using
emulators to emulate some
of these different
physical devices.
And so I want to go ahead and
talk a little bit about how
you set up an emulator, some
of the different options
you have, and also how we go
about speeding up emulator,
things like that.
OK, so the first step you
want to do when you're
creating an emulator
is you're going
to create something called
an Android virtual device.
So this is basically
just a representation
of the physical
device that allows
you to specify a variety
of different things
that you want your particular
emulator to look like.
So you'll notice,
in this case I have
it emulating a Galaxy Nexus.
I can specify which particular
OS I want to target.
CPU I want to target.
Currently, you can select
between ARM, Intel,
and a third.
AUDIENCE: NIPS?
[INAUDIBLE] NIPS?
MIKE WOLFSON: NIPS.
You can specify hardware,
keyboard, things like that.
If it has a camera, if it
doesn't have a camera, memory
footprint, and you can
also specify SD card,
things like that.
Now there's a couple
options at the bottom
that I want to
particularly call out,
because they are particularly
useful and particularly
functional.
The first one is Use Host GPU.
So this allows you to, if
your computer has a GPU,
it allows you to
leverage that to improve
the performance
of your emulator.
So it will attach that CPU.
I think that that's
only available
if you're using the HAXM
emulator, the Intel.
Is that correct?
I think you can
only the host GPU
if you're using an
Intel emulator, which
we'll get to in a second.
But the other really
great thing is Snapshot.
So if you guys have ever used
any virtual machine, VMware,
et cetera, when you close
the virtual machine,
there is functionality
that allows
you to save a snapshot
of that virtual machine
so the next time
you bring it up,
it brings it up to
that same place.
That's exactly what this
Snapshot functionality
does, because these are
basically virtual machines,
anyway, these emulator images.
So when you're
creating your AVD,
if you check that
snapshot button,
it allows you to enable
the snapshot functionality.
Then, when you're
launching your AVD,
you can select these
three buttons here
at the bottom, which allow
you to use the snapshot.
So the first time you
bring up your emulator,
you will Wipe User
Data, and then
have this Save To
Snapshot button enabled.
So generally what
I do is, I bring up
an emulator from scratch, I
go through the various startup
options that it presents
you, like there's the Android
overlays that say press OK to
put apps here, or whatever.
I go through all
those startup options,
so I have a fresh emulator
that has been started up,
and I've gotten through
all these startup dialogs,
and then I kill
it right there so
that I have a pristine emulator
that has been started up
and is in brand spanking
new fresh state.
Next time, when I start
my AVD, my emulator,
instead of having Wipe
User Data selected,
I have Launch From
Snapshot selected,
and not Save To Snapshot.
So next time, when I
start up this emulator,
it's going to start it up using
the snapshot that I just took.
And the great thing is it
changes the start up time
from, like I said, three,
four minutes, to seconds.
Maybe 10 seconds, 20 seconds.
If you're not using snapshots,
this will-- in fact,
if you leave here now, you just
learned something really good.
Snapshots will save
you a lot of time.
The other thing you
could do using snapshots
is if you do have a
particular state in your app
that you want to
test repeatedly,
you can bring your
app up to that state,
and then save that
state as your snapshot.
So you can always bring
up your fresh emulator
to exactly the point in the
code that you need to test.
OK, so we kind of touched on
some of these things before,
but there are alternatives to
using the Android emulators.
First one is Intel's HAXM.
So this allows you to create
emulators using the Intel
chipset.
So if your computer is running
an Intel chip instead of an AMD
chip, this is a
great thing to do.
Now, performance
wise, it's fine.
But the Intel HAXM emulator
is much faster to start up,
and much faster to deploy to.
So, right there
in and of itself,
it is a much faster experience
to be using the Intel HAXM
emulator.
Big giant limitation of HAXM
is that it doesn't support
the Google APIs, it only
supports the Android APIs.
So if you're doing anything
that requires Google APIs, GCM
or some of the other options
available to Android,
Intel HAXM is, unfortunately,
not available to use.
So if you're not
using the Google APIs,
Intel HAXM's really great.
I would really strongly
suggest you use it.
It supports snapshots just the
same as the standard emulator.
So there is also
another newcomer
on the block, called Genymotion.
And they provide,
basically, turnkey options
for generating emulators.
So instead of with HAXM or
the standard Android emulator,
I have to go through create
the emulator AVD that I think
is appropriate to my
needs, start it up,
et cetera, et cetera.
Genymotion provides
a really rich GUI
that allows you to
start from a variety
of pre-configured
emulator images.
The cool thing about previous
version of Genymotion,
and this has just changed
with their new release,
is the last version
of Genymotion
actually did support
full Play Services.
So it supported the Play store,
you could create a Google
account on a Genymotion
emulator, all those things.
Unfortunately, that
didn't last long,
because they just announced
in their next release
that that's going away.
I'm pretty sure, and of
course, we don't know,
because Genymotion
is a closed project,
I'm pretty sure
they use Intel HAXM.
It's really fast.
It's really robust.
The cool thing about both
Intel HAXM and Genymotion,
and this is one of those things
you might not key in on early,
but really makes a difference
in the development process,
is the deployment speed.
So it takes a little
bit of time to deploy
to an Android emulator.
Both HAXM and Genymotion,
the deployment time
is much more rapid.
So those are some things that
you might not key in on early,
but it makes a big
difference, especially
in your daily development
cycle that you're
deploying, deploying, deploying.
One sec, this guy.
AUDIENCE: You said
AMD several times.,
but you actually
meant ARM, right?
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah.
ARM, sorry.
The question is, I've been
saying AMD, do I mean ARM?
The answer is yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: Android Studio
uses the same emulators.
And I'm pretty sure you can use
Genymotion or HAXM, as well,
on Android Studio.
OK, so that's
enough of the tools.
Let's talk about coding.
There are a ton of really
great tools built into the ADT
that if you use them, will
save you a lot of time
and a lot of mistakes.
Android, as again,
you guys all know,
can be pretty challenging.
There's a lot of moving parts.
You have your XML
file, your Java file,
you have other external
configuration files,
for certain operations that
you're using a fragment,
you have multiple Java
files all connected.
It can be really challenging.
And if you mess up one piece,
one attribute in that XML file,
it can be a bear to
try to debug that.
There are a ton of automated
code generation tools,
that I'll show you in a moment,
that at least allow you to stub
out your initial code, so
that you're not fighting
the basic stuff, and you can
concentrate on the business
logic and the important
stuff, as opposed
to creating these foundations.
AUDIENCE: So, Gradle
made that easy.
MIKE WOLFSON: Gradle?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MIKE WOLFSON: How so?
The comment is,
Gradle made this easy.
AUDIENCE: There's not
too many moving parts.
[INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: Right.
Yeah, Gradle does make some
of these configuration things
easier, because of the
nature of their resource.
You can build multiple APKs
from different resources within.
Yeah.
So there's really great support
for Java and XML editing
that you can take advantage
of, and there's also
a really rich robust
visual editor that most
people probably
don't use, because it
used to kind of suck, basically.
OK, so let's talk a little
bit about some of the code
generation wizards
that you can use,
and why you really should
be using these things.
So to access any
of these wizards,
you can hit File,
New at the top,
or Control, or Command on Apple.
And that will bring up
this wizard selection.
You can see there's a
variety of different things
you can do in there.
You can create an icon set, you
can create a simple activity,
you can create an
Android XML file,
a variety of different things.
These are really
robust tools that
will allow you to just create
a simple code that you can then
go in and fill out
yourself later.
So let's start with
the first example,
and that's Android Icon Set.
So again, you guys
all know what a hassle
it is to come up with all
the different versions
of your icons.
You need to, first of
all, figure out what
size they need to
be, what folder
do they need to go in to?
Do I have XXHDPI for this
one, et cetera, et cetera.
It's a real challenge.
Not to mention, trying
to communicate that
to your graphic designer or
someone else on your team.
This Android Icon Set,
and the other thing
I will mention about
this particular tool
is there's a really--
in fact, this tools
good, that's built into Eclipse.
But this tool is based on a web
project called Android Asset
Studio.
Android Asset Studio,
remember that.
It's a website
that not only will
allow you to create your
different resolution images,
but Android Asset
Studio, the website,
allows you to create frames
for your screenshots,
or a variety of other
different really great things.
So this is just a subset
of what is on that website,
but let me just show you what
this particular thing allows
you to do.
So once you've selected
Create an Icon Set,
it's going to bring
up this wizard.
Basically what
this wizard allows
you to do is, you could
select an image that's
your own icon that you can
go select from anywhere
on your system, clip art, this
is the Android standard clip
art.
So if you want to make sure that
your settings icon matches what
the Android settings icon
is, it's all there for you,
and it's built right in.
Or you could create
a text one, which
is what is shown
here in this example.
So you can select
your different icon,
what you want your
icon to look like.
You can specify colors, change
all sorts of different things,
change the padding.
When you press Finish, it
actually will create the icons
and place them
within your project,
in the folders they're
supposed to go.
So it's going to create a
LDPI, HDPI, et cetera, image
in the proper resolution.
And also, it's going to put
those in the proper folders
with the proper name.
So the best way to import
images into your system,
even if your designer
has given it to you,
is bring up the image
using that image option,
and then allow Asset
Studio, or Asset,
to put that into
your project for you.
This saves a whole lot of
time, and just another workflow
thing that I use that has
been very successful for me.
When I'm creating my
graphics, I generally
know what name I want to use
and what graphics I need.
So what I'll do is, I'll
create a stubbed out
graphic just like this, maybe
AA or something red and ugly,
name it the proper thing,
put it in my resource folder.
Then, I actually
give that resource
folder to my graphic designer
and say, here's what I need.
And they know exactly what
size images they need to do,
and they know exactly the names.
So they can then put all those
images into that resource zip,
give it back to me, I copy it
into my project, and I'm done.
There's no imports,
and all the names match
and all the sizes match.
So that's something that has
taken me a long time to come up
with, but saves a
whole lot of time.
It's really challenging
to communicate
all the different resolutions.
OK, so that's Android
Asset Studio--
that's creating an asset, and
that's really, really useful.
I suggest everybody use that.
You can also generate great
code with these wizards.
And here's one of the
more complicated ones,
and it's a very common
use case, and that's
multiple fragments with
a list view on one side
and a detail view
on the other side.
And if you guys know
about Android development,
there's an adapter
involved, there's
an activity, two
fragments, and then
all the wiring that goes
between those things.
Some XML files, there's
a lot going on here.
This wizard allows you to walk
through a couple different
questions, specify the
names of the items you want
and the activities
that you're creating,
and it will generate
the stubs for the code
that you want to generate
and place that directly
into your project.
It's just a great first step
to allow you to stub out
all the things, the
wiring and the hard stuff.
And get down to the
nitty-gritty of writing code.
Ton of stuff to explore
in these code wizards.
The other thing I just want
to mention-- if you're not
happy with the code
wizards that they provide,
you can actually
create your own.
So frequently, in the
development process,
we create our own
frameworks and components
that fit our particular
business case.
You can actually create
your own template
and allow your developers
to just use the template
to stub out these foundations.
So really useful.
And it's these sort
of automation things
that just make the development
process so much more
efficient and so
much more effective.
The last thing I might
mention about generating
code this way-- because it's
all generated code compliant
Android design patterns.
So the naming
standards are matched.
The division of
workload, et cetera.
So it's a really great
way to get started.
I wanted to highlight six of
the most important keystrokes I
use in Eclipse.
And these are ones that
I use all the time.
The first one you guys
probably know about.
And that's code completion.
Control or Command, Space.
This works in both Java and XML.
So if you're trying
to figure out
what attributes you
need in your XML file--
was that wrap content or
fill parent or match parent?
I don't forget.
Android clone width
equals Control Space.
And it'll give you the list
of all your different options
that you can put in there.
That works in both Java and XML.
I'm sure you guys already
know about that one.
If you don't, that will
probably change your life.
One that you probably don't
know about that's also extremely
useful and that's kind of
universal is Control Command 1.
So if you highlight
anywhere in XML or Java,
you highlight a particular
component and hit Command 1,
it's going to provide
context-sensitive help based
on what it is that
you've selected.
So in some cases,
it may allow you
to extract that string
to the strings file.
We don't want to leave
hard-coded strings
in our Android files.
We want to extract
those to strings.XML.
That's something
this'll allow you to do.
But depending on what it
is that you've selected,
it will provide
context-specific things.
So there may be
refactoring help.
If you're on a layout parent, or
depending on what you're doing.
So if you need help, highlight
something, Command 1.
And it will provide you a lot
of different functionality.
And then the last one.
This page is Command
Shift F. This
allows you to reformat your code
to change indentation or change
the formatting.
The cool thing is this has
specific functionality for XML.
It will change your
formatting, change
your tabs, et cetera,
so everything lines up.
It will also re-order
your XML attributes.
So if generally
you want ID, width,
height to be the top attributes,
et cetera, et cetera.
There's an order that you
want your attributes in.
And if the coder's not
careful, the attributes
are all out of order.
Control shift f will actually
reorder all the attributes so
that they are in
exactly the order
that the Android design
standards specify.
And, if you don't
like that order,
you can specify your own.
So Command Shift F is really
useful, both in Java and XML,
to ensure that your
formatting is consistent.
Consistent with Android
and also consistent
across all your entire project.
Great, navigation.
So these items were
key combinations
that will allow you to create
code and speed through some
of these things.
This page covers
navigation commands.
So the first one I
wanted to talk about
is Command O. So anywhere
within an XML file or Java file,
if you hit Command
O, it will show you
a outline view of your code
with the methods highlighted,
so you can quickly just
navigate with your arrow key
to the method that you want.
Rather than trying to
search through your code,
and scrolling up and down.
Command O, quickly
look for the method
you want to go to, click
on it, and you're there.
Another great way to
navigate around a project
is Command Shift
R or T, actually.
Command Shift T has a
more robust filter set.
Command Shift R, from
anywhere in your system
you can start typing the name
of a file you're looking for.
And if you're using camel case,
you just use the first letter.
So camel case means
uppercase C-O-D-E uppercase
P-R-O-J-E-C-T. You can type
CP, and it will find that code
project file.
Command Shift R is
a really great way
to quickly find different
files that you're looking for.
And then the last one
that's really useful
is Alt Shift A. This allows
you to quickly run or debug
your app without having to right
mouse click on the project,
Run As.
Or, I don't know if you guys
ever notice, but there's
a little Play symbol up
in the Eclipse toolbar
that allows you to
also run really quick.
That's another
quick way to do it.
Alt Shift A allows
you to quickly run
your app from anywhere.
So that's commands, shortcuts.
I now want to talk a little
bit about the Visual Editor.
My guess is-- and
this was the case
with me-- anybody who that
the Visual Editor years ago
decided that it's
just not very good.
It puts a bunch of code.
It doesn't really work.
You're going to
struggle with trying
to get things lined up the
way you want them to be,
et cetera, et cetera.
The tool is much,
much better now.
Basically, it allows
you to drag and drop
components from the left-hand
drawer right onto your palate.
And you can arrange all
your components as you want.
It also allows, on
the right-hand side,
these property editors allow
you to very quickly select
different properties
on different components
within your UI.
So if you have a button
and you select it,
the properties will allow you to
specify gravity or width or any
of those things.
Instead of needing
to type them, you
can go through the
selection criteria
and quickly select whatever
it is that you want.
But the one thing that I
really want to highlight.
All right, Mike, that
all sounds pretty cool.
But I'm a coder.
I like to do stuff by hand.
You still really
should be checking
out this Visual Editor
for this bar here.
Because what this bar allows
you to do is within the IDE,
it allows you to change the
visual style representative
of what you're looking at.
In addition to, as I have set
up here now, and now you'll see,
actually you can look
at how your app will
look on multiple devices.
So if you'll see, in this
screen I have a 3.2 HVGA image.
A 5.1 WVGA.
A 10.1 WXGA image.
And I can quickly
look at exactly how
my app is going to render on all
of those devices in one place.
So the way that you get there is
where it's selected Nexus One,
you can go into
that menu, and it
will allow you to select
which of the different images
you want to preview your app on.
In theory, you can actually
make changes in real time
and see how that's
going to lay out
in all of those
different image sizes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: So the question
is, years ago, people
used tools like Droid Draw
or some other different tools
to stub out their visual UI.
Is this good enough now that
you don't need to use that?
I think the answer is yes.
There's a really robust
set of things you can do.
The other thing I
will mention on this
is, in addition to specifying
different resolution screens
that you want to
look at, you can also
specify API levels
using this selection.
Or you can use this
one to actually look
at your internationalization.
So if you have enabled German
language, French language,
et cetera on your
app, you can actually
select those from this drop down
and see how your app lines up
when you're using German
characters or something.
And obviously, that's
really important,
because certain
language character
sets are bigger than others.
And this allows you very
quickly to modify your UI
and understand exactly how
it's going to look right here,
really quick.
There's no deploy cycle.
There's no fiddling with your
phone to change the locale.
It's all just right here.
So even if you're not going to
use the Visual Editor to drag
and drop components
and select properties,
I would really
highly suggest that
at least when you're
testing, that you bring
your app in this
visual editor and play
with the different
resolutions and things.
So we're coming up
to the last section.
And that's performance testing
and performance monitoring.
So the first thing that
I wanted to make everyone
aware of that you
might not know is
there's something called
the Tools Monitor.
So if you type "Tools
Monitor" from your--
if you have Android home set,
you don't need to put the path.
Do you guys know what DDMS is?
The different tools
that allow you to--
Monitor actually allows
you to run all the DDMS
tools external to Eclipse.
I'm going to show
you that, and you'll
see that it's exactly
the same as DDMS.
The cool thing is,
this would allow
you to tell people that
don't have the IDE installed,
it allows them to run some
of these performance tools
and introspect some
of the functionality
without requiring the full IDE
install, or importing a project
and doing all those tough things
that maybe a tester might not
want to do, or a
project manager.
So you can bring up
the performance tools
using Monitor, like this
Android device monitor.
Or if you're in Eclipse, you
can show open perspective DDMS.
OK.
So this is what the DDMS or
Monitor window looks like.
You'll notice on the
left, it has a list
of devices you
currently have running,
which allows you to select from
all those different devices.
On the top right,
there's all sorts
of different
functionality that allows
you to introspect different
things within your app.
Now, DDMS is really designed
for in-depth performance
monitoring.
So this is where
you're going to want
to inspect how your threads are
running, if you have threads
that aren't being
closed properly,
or your heap allocation,
if you're getting Out
of Memory errors.
Allocation tracker.
Where your objects are being
allocated within your heap.
Network statistics get
really in-depth information
about what calls
are being made when,
and what kind of data throughput
is going through those.
File Explorer, it's
a GUI that allows
you to look on your phone
using-- introspect your file
system.
You can then pull or
push files to the file
system on your phone using that.
Then the emulator is
the tab I have exposed.
This allows you to set--
if you want to send latency
on your device, simulate a
phone call, simulate a location,
this is where you would do that.
So some important
things that I want
to make sure everybody--
well, I guess
we already covered
most of these things.
But the one thing that most
people can really use out
of this screen--
and by most people,
this is not even developers--
is this little icon right here.
This allows you to
select a device,
bring your app up
on that device.
You press that
button, and it will
take a screen shot of whatever's
being shown on your device.
So that's super useful,
because obviously,
we all need to take
screenshots for demos
or promotional materials.
Upload pictures to the
Play Market, whatever.
This is much easier than
trying to press up and power
on the phone at
just the right time,
and then trying to
get that file off.
So that's a really
useful aspect of DDMS,
is taking a screenshot.
OK.
So I think we already
covered those things.
The last tool that I
really want to talk about
that I think people might not
be aware of but is super useful,
especially for
performance optimization,
is Hierarchy Viewer.
So what this allows
you to do is this
allows you to inspect the
visual hierarchy of your UI,
and see where you might
have extra layouts.
In Android, the fewer
layouts the better.
If you have a bunch
of nested layouts
due to the way that the
view is measured and drawn,
the more layouts you have,
the longer it takes to render.
And that's obviously bad.
That causes
performance problems.
So this very quickly
allows you to look
at your UI on a visual level and
see what your hierarchy looks
like, and try to determine any
places where you can optimize.
A optimal layout is
flat and shallow.
This is not as optimal a layout.
It's got lots of
different levels.
So this really allows
you very quickly
to see exactly how
your UI's laid out
and how it's performing.
In addition-- and
unfortunately, you can't really
see in this
screenshot-- it actually
shows you measurement
times in that pop-up.
So you can very quickly run the
Hierarchy Viewer on your UI,
see how long it took to
render, make optimizations,
run Hierarchy Viewer
again, and see
how your optimizations
affected the layout times.
In that project that I
referenced previously,
I have two layouts.
One's called Bad Layout and
one's called Good Layout.
When you look at them
on the device itself,
they look exactly the same.
The buttons are all placed
in exactly the same place.
The UI does exactly
the same thing.
However, one of them was
written with a relative layout,
so it's all very flat and
not a lot of nested layouts.
The other is written using
a bunch of nested layouts,
a bunch of linear
layout of horizontal
and vertical orientation
all mashed together.
I encourage you guys to actually
run those two side by side
and inspect what a
good layout looks like
and what a bad
layout looks like.
The same exact layout
in that example
runs 20% faster using
the relative layout.
So again, it looks
exactly the same,
but as an optimized version
it runs almost a fifth faster.
AUDIENCE: How many layers
is considered optimal?
MIKE WOLFSON: So the question
is, how many layers of layout
is considered optimal?
And the answer is it depends.
There's no hard and fast rules.
Layouts can be complicated,
and sometimes they
require a bunch of
different nested layouts.
Sometimes that's
the only way to get
it done, dealing with
weights or other things.
The answer is it depends.
But the real answer
to that is as few
as you can get away with.
AUDIENCE: Better user
experience with less levels?
MIKE WOLFSON: Yes.
These fewer levels of
layouts that you have,
the better user experience,
the faster your UI
is going to render, and the
less resources-- well, it
probably takes the
same resources.
But fewer layouts, more better.
OK.
I wanted to just touch on
some other performance tools.
We're almost done here, just
to let you guys know that.
Some other tools that I'm
not able to demo here,
but I want you guys to be aware
of so you know that they exist.
First one is OpenGL Tracer.
So if you're using
OpenGL within your app,
this allows you to
trace very specifically
through all of your
GL calls, so that you
can see exactly what's happening
throughout your code rendering.
I don't do a lot
of OpenGL myself.
I don't do that sort
of graphic stuff.
But really, really useful
if you're doing OpenGL.
Really, really useful
to be able to see
exactly what it is
that you're doing.
So again, all these
tools are just
allowing us to get a closer look
at how our code is operating
so that we really
understand and that we
can optimize where
it's most effective.
Pixel Perfect Viewer
allows you to look
at very close
renditions of your UI
so that you can isolate
shadow problems or any sort
of dithering or other issues
that you might have in your UI.
Network Statistics we
already talked about.
That allows you very,
very close understanding
of exactly what's happening
with your network calls.
You can trace the size of
the calls, the duration,
et cetera, et cetera.
System Information gives
you a really good overview
of your device.
The memory it's
used, the memory it
has available, space on the
device, things like that.
It shows you that in
some really nice charts.
So it's a really clear visual
representation of exactly
and what resources are
available to your device.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
app that runs
for a long duration of time or
a background service [INAUDIBLE]
battery doesn't get
drained within two hours.
And if they [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE WOLFSON: So
the question is,
if you're dealing with an
app that might suck battery
or might use a lot of power,
does the system information
provide that?
I don't know.
I'll look at that in a second.
I don't know of a good
tool to track that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: There is a
company in India that does that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Facebook isn't going to buy it.
Does anyone remember?
Something [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah.
So real quick we'll go
through these last ones.
And then I think we're
good to close this out.
So Lint is a automated
testing tool, basically.
It's going to, in your
code as it's live,
it will flag certain things in
your code that are either wrong
or that are just bad.
So for instance, like we
talked about before, if you're
using a hard-coded
string within your code,
Lint will go through
automatically
and it'll put a little flag
next to that says, hey,
you probably don't want to be
using a hard-coded string here.
And then, when you
mouse over that,
it will give you
remediation strategies.
And in some cases, will actually
go ahead and fix those for you.
So in this case, Lint
will highlight that.
You will click on that
particular string.
And then it will provide you
the button that says Export this
String to strings.XML..
So Lint is run automatically.
It can also be run as part
of your build to flag things.
It's much like PMD or Find
Bugs in the Java world.
Basically, an
automated testing tool
to highlight patterns and
not functional problems,
but code problems.
AUDIENCE: So is
there a tool that
will tell you what the
minimal Android version is
that you should
target your app to?
MIKE WOLFSON: So the
question is, is there
a tool that will tell you
what the minimum Android
OS is to target.
And the answer is no, because
that's fully dependent on you.
You need to decide who
you want to support.
So there's no tool
that can tell you that.
Now, it obviously depends on
the APIs you need to support
and your customer base.
But there's no rules for that.
That's completely subjective.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you might
write code and it could say,
if you want to target
an older version,
you shouldn't be using--
MIKE WOLFSON: It will tell
you if you have API issues.
It will tell you if you're using
an API that's not supported
in the version of the OS
you're targeting, actually.
So that is one of the things
that it will tell you.
Monkey is basically a tool
that is designed to be,
if 1,000 tiny monkeys
were using your app,
pressing it all
at the same time.
This is basically
chaos testing, to see
if a bunch of different
presses happen
on your app, what would happen?
If it'll crash, if
it'll cause issues.
Monkey Runner, not at
all the same thing.
Monkey Runner is
a scripting tool
that basically uses Perl scripts
to allow you to do automated UI
tests using this monkey
runner scripting tool.
Really useful.
Memory Allocation Tracker.
Now, this is an
Eclipse tool, but it's
built directly into
the ADT and allows you
to-- the tools are built
directly into the ADT.
You can I dump a a [? mat ?]
profile directly from DDMS.
This allows you very,
very good inspection
into the memory of your app.
So provides all sorts
of options to determine
how your heap's being allocated.
And it will also provide a
bunch of different options
for how to improve your memory.
So that's an Eclipse
tool, but it's
built directly into
the ADT and is really
a valuable tool to use.
The last one that I
just want to mention--
and we have addressed this on a
high level a little bit later.
This is a external project,
an open source project
called Sensor Simulator Project.
So we mentioned with
emulators, there's
certain things that
you can't emulate.
Sensors being for one, motion
sensors or touch, other things.
This sensor simulator
project actually
allows you to both
record sensor operations
and play them back in
an automated fashion.
Or, if you just want to simulate
sensor operations, meaning
again, motion
sensors or whatever,
it'll allow you to simulate
those on the emulator.
So if you're needing
to write functionality
that the emulator can't
support using sensors,
that's a really great project
and a really great way
to make that happen.
OK.
I think we're done.
I did want to make sure that
I put some reference points up
on the screen for
where you can go
to learn more about the tools.
First one we
already put up there
is the Android Developer
Tools official project site.
Tons of useful
information there.
Lots of help articles.
And more importantly, they
also have their project plan.
What they plan on doing,
what they plan on supporting.
You can put help
requests in there.
You can put bug
They're very open about
what they're working on
and what their plans
are, and it's all
contained on that website.
Really, really useful.
Stack Overflow.
I hope most of the
people in this room
already know about it.
If you have a question--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah.
Someone has already asked
it on Stack Overflow,
and hopefully has answered it.
Really useful.
There is a Google group
specifically for Android
Developer Tools developers.
And there's the link for that.
Right now there's a lot of noise
about Android Studio and Gradle
in there.
So if you're working on
either of those two tools,
that seems to be consuming most
of the messages in that group.
But the Tools
guys, the guys that
work for Google on
the Tools project,
they're actively in that
group answering questions
and helping people.
So it's a great resource
for researching things
if you don't have the answer.
Last really great resource is
the Android Developer Tools
Essentials Book, available now
from O'Reilly on Amazon.com.
OK.
That's it.
I think we already
answered all the questions.
I just wanted to make sure
that people have access
to the GitHub repo slide share.
And then if you'd like to follow
me on Twitter or circle me
on Google+, I would
love to connect.
So thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]